[MUSIC PLAYING]
SIMON PERKOWSKI:
Greetings, everyone.
I'm Simon Perkowski.
I'm very excited to introduce
Seth Grahame-Smith here today.
He's a "New York
Times" bestselling
author, screenwriter,
producer, and director.
He sold over two million
copies of "Pride and Prejudice
and Zombies" as well as "Abraham
Lincoln, Vampire Hunter,"
both of which have been
adapted for the big screen.
He is working with Tim Burton
on a sequel to the 1988 classic,
"Beetlejuice," producing
Stephen King's "It,"
and a spin-off to
"The Lego Movie."
Today, he's going to
talk about his new novel,
"The Last American
Vampire," a sequel
to "Abraham Lincoln,
Vampire Hunter."
It was just released this month.
So with that,
let's welcome Seth.
[APPLAUSE]
SETH GRAHAME-SMITH: Thank you.
Thanks, Simon.
Thank all of you for taking
time out of your day to come
and, I guess, be part of
the inaugural talk at Google
here at the Tech Corners campus.
I'll be your Guinea
pig for today,
and I'll try to keep it
light and interactive.
So what I typically
like to do is just
talk for maybe
seven to 10 minutes,
and then while I'm
talking, if you guys
think of questions or things
you want to yell at me
or challenge me on or et cetera,
then we can have a conversation
rather than just make
this a monologue.
It's always more
fun for me that way.
So it's interesting
being here at Google--
and I've done talks
at other Google sites
before-- because I
think that you guys are
in the middle of what
publishing is going to look
like in a few years.
I think it's no secret that
physical book sales are
plummeting-- and that's
putting it kindly.
Barnes and Noble
is the only chain
left in the United
States of any real power,
and they are closing stores.
Borders is gone.
I think Walden books is
either gone or almost gone.
It's very, very hard
to find shelf space
to sell a physical
book these days.
And yet people are
reading more than ever.
They're reading
on their Kindles,
they're reading on
their iPads, they're
reading on their phones on
the train on the way to work.
They're listening to books in
their earphones on Audible.
So it's not that
stories are dead.
It's not that the sky is
falling and that no one's
going to read anymore.
But the way that
people are reading
is changing faster than most
people can even keep up.
And I was telling Simon
before we began today
that I was on my way to an event
at a physical bookstore in New
York last week.
And to get people to come
out to a physical bookstore
in 20-degree weather on a
week night in a big city
where there's a lot of
distractions is very hard.
And I knew it was going
to be one of those
we'll-be-lucky-to-have-20-people
kind of events.
And sure enough, as I'm
driving through Times Square
to go to the event, there
is a huge video wall
in Times Square.
And there's a Google
Play add playing,
the size of a building.
And there's this big book
that says, play books.
And it's just rotating.
And it just felt like
there's a message here.
Somebody's telling me something.
And I think that what
you're going to see
is you're going to
see authors continue
to publish physical books.
I think there's always going to
be a market for the physical,
to some degree.
But I think you're going to see
authors self-publishing more--
and I'm not talking about
people who are starting out.
I'm talking about people
who've sold a lot of books.
You're going to see
them self-publish
or you're going to see
them doing partnerships
with Google Play, with
Amazon, and so on and so
forth because you
guys here at Google
have a broader reach in terms of
aggregating content or pushing
people to media
than any publishing
company in the world,
probably all the publishing
companies in the world combined.
And so for storytellers like
myself who on the movie and TV
side have begun doing
direct deals with Netflix
for original movies
and original shows,
direct deals-- just the other
day we read about Amazon
is now going to get into the
theatrical movie business,
in the $5 to $25 million range.
They're going to do a short
theatrical window followed
by an Amazon Prime
exclusive right
after the theatrical
window closes.
That's the norm.
It's not that, oh, this is going
to be 5 to 10 years from now
we'll have to start
thinking about.
No, it's here.
Publishing in the way
we knew it is over.
Hollywood distribution
and production the way
we knew it is over.
And that's great because we
shouldn't be afraid of it.
We should be
celebrating the fact
that we have more
opportunities as storytellers
to reach people.
And we have more
opportunities to reach
a targeted group of people.
I mean, say you write a
book about-- you're really
into science fiction about
ducks, just as a weird example
that I don't know
why I just said it.
But in the world
of five years ago,
no one's going to buy a book for
that niche market of people who
love ducks and love
science fiction.
But now in today's world,
since it costs almost nothing
to distribute electronically,
if you can find someone
willing to put up just
a tiny bit of money--
even if you do it yourself-- to
package that however you have
to format it for
ebooks-- you can now
publish a book about ducks
in a science fiction universe
and reach the three people
who would read that book.
But that's OK.
And the same is true of an
Amazon Prime show or a Netflix
show.
The same is true of, frankly,
a premium cable show.
You don't have to
reach 20 million people
in order to make it
make economic sense.
So I get excited being
here because being here
is kind of the opposite
of the way I usually
feel when I walk
onto a studio lot
or into a big publishing house.
There is explosive
growth and nothing
but upside in this building.
And the opportunities
are presenting themselves
on an almost daily basis in
terms of what Google can do.
When I published "Abraham
Lincoln, Vampire Hunter"
five years ago, it was roughly
a 50-50 ebook to physical book
ratio, maybe 60-40 in favor
of physical, actually.
Now, five years later
with all those bookstores
that I named earlier,
those chains closed,
there is half the retail
space in the United States
that there was five
years ago for books.
That means half the
shelf space for us
to put our books on for people
to wander into bookstores,
find your book, pull it
off the shelf, and buy it.
So the ratio is
now closer to 70-30
in favor of digital, or
ebook, versus physical.
So the writing's on the wall.
And I think that you're
going to see publishers--
and again, I'm talking
about the James Pattersons
and the Preston and Childs
and the Stephen Kings, even.
I think you're going to
start seeing them experiment
with direct to digital.
And I think you're going to
see people do a publishing
deal with a Google or with
an Amazon directly instead
of going through a Random
House, a Simon and Schuster.
And I'm sure someone
at my publisher's
going to see this talk
online and freak out,
and I'm going to get a call.
But I'm happy, you guys.
I'm good.
I'm not going anywhere yet.
I owe you one more book,
contractually, anyway.
So I can't.
But it's an exciting time.
It's a scary time to be in
media as a content creator.
And the first thing that any of
the quote, unquote "old guard
producers" that I
meet will tell you
is, well, you're not going to
make the kind of money I made.
And they love telling
you that because
in the heyday of the
'80s and the '90s
when producers and
directors were getting
25% of first dollar
gross-- which
means that for
every ticket sold,
they get 25% right off the
top into their pockets--
those deals are gone.
Those producer deals are over.
The Joel Silvers of
the '80s, that's gone.
You have to now
be lean and mean.
It's not about
sending in a platoon
to make a movie anymore.
It's about sending
in a SEAL team.
And that means everybody has
to know how to do seven things.
So for a guy like me
who-- I can write a movie,
I can direct a movie,
I can produce a movie--
it's actually a
pretty good time to be
getting into the business.
And for you guys, as a company,
it's just extraordinary.
You think about the
fact that this company
didn't exist 15 years ago.
And now you can't build
the buildings fast enough.
You're outgrowing campuses.
It's just extraordinary.
And it's exciting
to think about what
that means for somebody like me.
I also told Simon that--
and I'm not just saying this
because I'm at Google--
but I am a Chrome user.
And the Chrome
browser will be open
whenever I'm writing a
book because my books tend
to deal with a lot of history,
and they're very research
intensive.
And even as I'm writing, I've
got like 20 Wikipedia tabs
open.
And I'm just shuttling around
between tabs in the browser
or typing something in to
verify something and make
sure it's historically accurate.
And then the fact that we
made this book trailer just
to premiere on YouTube
because, again, Google
is part of the way
we reach people.
Google is now the way
that I research my books
and write them, and Google
is now a huge part of the way
that I reach out to
my readers and let
them know the book exists.
And I think that
kind of partnership
is only becoming more strong.
And eventually, I think
that-- as much as I
hate to say it because
I love physical books,
and I grew up in a very physical
book oriented household--
I think that you're
going to be able to buy
physical books in boutiques.
And everybody else is
going to be downloading.
And as long as we can figure
out how to reach those people
and get them excited
about stories,
then, frankly, how they
consume them is up to them.
I'm not a purist in
the sense of, well,
physical books are far
superior because you
can feel the weight of them.
You know what?
It's not about that.
All the purists.
The people who will tell you
that vinyl sounds better--
and I'm sure it does.
But it's not about whether
you listen to it on vinyl
or listen to it as an mp3.
It's the content.
It's the song.
And it's not about whether
you read it on your phone--
although that's bad
for your eyes, people--
or curled up by the fire with
a heavy 1,000 page novel.
It's the story.
So I guess we'll see.
And there are people who will
vehemently disagree with that.
There are people who
say it's not the same.
Well, to them I say, whether
or not it is or isn't, it's
irrelevant.
We're going that way.
So it's get on or get off.
And I'm excited to
get on because I
want to keep
writing books, and I
want people to
keep reading them.
Anyway, so just take
a couple minutes.
And then I want
to hear questions
because I really like
to be more interactive.
I did grow up in a very
bookcentric household.
My mother was an editor for
a small publishing company
in Connecticut, still is.
My stepfather ran a bookstore,
and he had a mail-order book
business.
And so our basement at
home was all shelves.
And there was literally
the type of thing
where you were always
stepping over a pile of books
in our house.
And we had 5,000
volumes in the basement.
My stepfather was always
down there doing something.
And he was really into fantasy
and science fiction and horror.
And so when I was
a kid growing up,
it was Bradbury and
Heinlein and Asimov.
And it was King
and it was Koontz.
And at a very
inappropriately early age,
I started grabbing those
books off the shelves
and sneaking little--
there's something
exciting about
reading "The Shining"
when you're eight-- and
horrible at the same time.
And I became infatuated.
And I became infatuated
with reading.
And for anyone who does
any writing of their own,
there's only two ways
to get any good at it.
And that's write a
lot and read a lot.
That's it.
Secret's out.
And so I did a lot of that.
I wrote my stories.
And yet, I was fascinated
with the movies.
From my little town
in Connecticut,
I had no connection
to the movie business.
I didn't know anything about it.
But I was fascinated.
And instead of
cutting out pictures
of sports heroes
and Lamborghinis--
this was the '80s, so
Lamborghinis-- I cut out
pictures of Francis Ford
Coppola from "Premiere" magazine
and pasted them on my wall
like they were my idols.
And so I was that kid.
And I was the kid who had his
own show on the public access
station and ran around
with the big VHS camera
making the movies at school
and not extremely popular,
but that's OK.
And so I went to film school.
And the whole thing was
about going out to LA
and getting that big film job.
And for about 10 years, I was
just another struggling writer
in LA, writing at
night, going to my job
by day and sort of on
the big hamster wheel,
not getting anywhere.
And it was only when I went
back and wrote a book, "Pride
and Prejudice and Zombies,"
about six years ago
that my film career took off.
And so it was strange that
this book background that I
had come from and this
fascination with books as a kid
is ultimately what led me
to the movies, in a way.
And so now I'm lucky
enough to be involved
in a lot of the things
that Simon mentioned
and to have worked with
a lot of the people
that I used to have
plastered on my wall, which
is weird and exciting and scary.
And I've learned a tremendous
amount from those people
and from having gone through
the process of making movies
now a couple times,
spectacularly falling on
my face at least
once or twice in
and learning from
that experience.
And so here I am.
So does anyone have a question?
I can keep talking
until-- all right.
So I see-- yes, sir?
Oh, and he's going to
make his way to the mic
because we're going to
do the-- please bring
your questions to the mic.
This is like a
town hall meeting.
Yes.
Yes, citizen?
AUDIENCE: The first
"Beetlejuice" film
ended with Beetlejuice in a
waiting room with this ticket
number saying about 9 trillion.
In that way it's taken
25 years to do a sequel?
SETH GRAHAME-SMITH: Yes.
That's exactly it.
It was always planned that way.
Yeah, if you look it's
actually 28 years this year.
Is it 28?
No, it's next year is 28 years.
27 years.
No, I think that the scariest
thing about potentially doing
a "Beetlejuice"
sequel is the fact
that I feel like
as a writer, there
are only degrees of how
badly I can screw it up.
It's not it's not about degrees
of how well I can do it.
It's about, from the get-go--
because the first film
is so original
and doesn't really
beg for a sequel in
any way shape, or form.
And it's been 27 years.
And the world has gotten on
just fine without a sequel--
although, maybe that's
why there's ISIS.
But at the same time, I
know that it's something
that Tim was excited about
returning to and something
that Michael Keaton was
excited about returning to.
And based on the
fact that it's always
the first question
I get anywhere I go,
it's something
that is still very
much in the public
consciousness.
Now, is that a
reason to make it?
No.
But if we make it
well, then maybe
we can become a
self-justifying film?
I don't know.
But I wrote the draft
a couple years ago,
and we've been sort
of kicking around
how we're going to get a made.
And if it comes together,
and I hope it does,
it'll be a very
scary year for me
because I'll be just
walking that tight rope.
I don't know what it is
about me and touching
third rails of cultural
significance-- Abraham
Lincoln, the Bible, Jane Austen.
Yeah, I just can't help myself.
But thank you.
Yes, sir?
AUDIENCE: For years, kind
of getting onto shelves
and getting really
publicized required
working with a production
team and the editors.
And not only does
that do the gating,
it, also gets them to help push
you to edit and to move things,
to become higher
quality, at least
according to their standards.
I wonder what you
think will end up
happening as you no
longer are, as an author,
required to work with
a professional editor.
SETH GRAHAME-SMITH:
That's a good question.
There has always
been a relationship,
as far back as any
real publishing goes.
Let's say, just for argument's
sake, the 17th or 18th century,
when you would sell your works
as a serial in a magazine
and then turn them into a novel.
Certainly in Hollywood, going
back to the dawn of Hollywood,
there's always been the
producer, the studio.
There's this relationship
between creator and aggregator.
And that relationship, and
the collaborative nature
of that relationship, ultimately
makes content better--
in theory anyway, and
most of the time it does.
I think that no matter what
happens to the distribution--
whether we're
talking about you're
selling your books
directly through Amazon
or through Google, you're
selling your movie directly
through Amazon or through
Netflix or what have you
or just putting it on YouTube--
I think that the things that
will be the most successful
will be the aggregated content.
I think that they will
be the edited content.
I think that there will always
be some kind of relationship
there because you can't--
there are people who can create
in a vacuum, all right?
But not all of us are
Paul Thomas Anderson
or Upton Sinclair.
We're not all these sort
of self-reliant geniuses.
Certainly, I'm not.
I benefit from the
interaction with an editor
or with a producer or director,
an actor, other writers.
I don't always like the process
of getting notes and having
to respond to them.
But getting challenged--
I mean, I say to people,
your work is going to be
exposed at one point or another.
Would you like it to be exposed
in a small group of people
talking about it at a table?
Or would you like
it to be exposed
when it goes out into the world
and gets horrible reviews?
So I think that the work that
is going to continue to be
the top notch is going
to be the stuff that's
been put through some
kind of editorial process.
But, I mean, you could
also point to the fact
that there are-- I don't
know, you guys tell me.
How many YouTube videos
get uploaded every minute,
every hour, every day?
Of those tens of thousands,
hundreds of thousands,
millions of videos, maybe-- just
to pull a statistic completely
out of my butt-- one
thousandth of 1% of those
will cume more than 100,000
views or even 10,000 views.
It's probably
something staggering.
So it's still a very,
very small portion
of things that aren't
produced in some kind
of professional sphere or with
some kind of editorial hurdle
that they have to
clear that actually
break through and are actually
of any creative significance,
I guess, if that
makes any sense.
Anyone?
Bueller?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Do you
still read books?
SETH GRAHAME-SMITH: Oh, yeah.
All the time.
I still read books
because it's my craft.
And you can't
create in a vacuum.
And you can't exist as a
creator without knowing
what else is being created.
For the same reason that
when I'm writing a TV
show about a certain subject
or for a certain network,
I immerse myself in it.
Because I want to know,
realistically-- I also
want to know who's
doing it better, always.
But the most important
reason is I love to do it.
I mean, I have a book--
well, I have an iPad with me.
But the book I'm reading right
now on the road these last two
weeks, doing this book tour,
is "In the Garden of Beasts"
by Erik Larson, which is
a terrific-- if you ever
read "The Devil in
the White City,"
the story of the serial
killer at the World
Expo in the late
1800s, I think it was.
Erik Larson is a
fantastic guy who
knows how to tell a nonfiction
historical story in a very sort
of almost fictional way.
It's very sensational.
I get inspired by
watching films by people
who make films better than I do.
I get inspired by
reading people who
write more elegantly or
more viscerally than I do.
And I steal from them,
which is the best.
You just steal the
tricks that work.
What is that?
The good artists imitate,
the great artists steal.
And I still curl up with a
Stephen King all the time.
I never grew out of that.
That teenage boy still
loves me some Stephen King.
I read every new thing
when it comes out.
I read his 1999
book, "On Writing,"
every year around the holidays.
It's sort of a refresher course.
If anyone in here is
interested in writing fiction,
do yourself a favor
and pick that book up
because I don't
know anyone who's
boiled the craft down to a sort
of more accessible and folksy
wisdom type of essence
than he did in that book.
Yes, sir?
AUDIENCE: So to move the
conversation a little bit
back towards [INAUDIBLE]
or in this case the book,
I wanted to see when you
were writing this new book,
what sort of historical
inspirations did you take?
Were you sitting down
with a AP European history
textbook saying,
there's a vampire
in here in some
ways, not others?
Like, how did you approach
the new time frame?
SETH GRAHAME-SMITH: Right.
Well, I knew this was going
to be the story continuing
from the first book.
The first book was essentially
the story of Abe Lincoln's
life, and culminated
in the Civil War.
So essentially, you're talking
about Abe was killed in 1865.
So that was the end of story.
And there is a little
epilogue at the end
of that book where we
jump ahead 98 years
and sort of tease something
that might have happened.
And so that was the inspiration
for this story is well,
what was that 98 years
that we didn't learn about
at the very end?
And I kept missing
these characters
and wanting to go back to them.
And I had such fun
writing the first book.
And I thought, well, that 98
years is the story of America.
It's the American century.
And where in the
first book we only
had the Civil War, in this
book we have two world wars,
we have Vietnam, we have the
space race, we have Hitler,
we have the Hindenburg,
we have Soviet Union,
we have the rise of anarchy
and the industrial age.
And there's so
much history there.
And telling the story of
the last American vampire
against the backdrop of,
really, the American century
seemed like it would
be a lot of fun.
And it was, but it was
also a lot of work.
And then I just
did what I always
do, which is I
looked at the broad--
the sort of Howard Zinn
"People's History of the United
States" version of
the 20th century--
and then looked at the
events that were the most
cataclysmic and the so-called
turning point events,
and then started to lay those
out and go, OK, well then,
how would the story
intersect here?
And how would their-- meaning
Abe and Henry's-- sort
of involvement in, say,
World War I then lead
to their involvement in pre-Nazi
Germany or brown shirt Germany?
So it was just a process
of whittling down
to the major things
that I wanted to do
and then researching intensely
those specific things
and outlining a story that
would weave me through it.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Have you
developed a ritual?
So in my mind, I'm thinking
of "Misery" and James Caan.
SETH GRAHAME-SMITH:
That is basically
how I approach writing.
Yeah.
My keyboard is my Annie.
She hobbles me every day.
Yes, I'm sorry.
But what was your--
AUDIENCE: Do you have a ritual?
Have you developed
a ritual over time
now that you do
before or after or--
SETH GRAHAME-SMITH: Yes.
Heavy, heavy breathing
exercises and yoga-- no.
Heavy, heavy coffee
consumption, unfortunately.
My ritual is that I
treat writing like a job.
I do it seven days a week, no
matter where in the world I am,
even if I do it on a
plane or on a pad of paper
between meetings.
I have note files
on my phone that
run very deep in terms
of continuing stories
where I left off.
But mostly, when I'm in home
base, which is Los Angeles,
I have an office
in the city where
I go Monday through Friday.
I show up in the morning,
sit down at my desk,
and I write for
about three hours.
And then the middle of the day
is for emails, calls, meetings,
other projects, film
projects, television.
And then I have lunch,
and then I come back,
and I do another two and a half,
three hours in the afternoon.
And those are my roughly
six hours-- five and a half,
six hours of writing a
day, Monday through Friday.
If I'm writing a book, or if
it's an especially intense
time, I'll add a
third shift at home.
I'll go to the home office.
I'll put my two little sons in
the bathtub and put them to bed
and get a third cup of coffee
and say, good night, wife,
and go and disappear into
my hellhole for another two
hours, probably--
two, three hours,
depending on what I'm doing.
And then on the
weekends, usually it's
doing dad stuff during the
day and then writing at night.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
SETH GRAHAME-SMITH:
Thank you very much.
Yes, sir?
AUDIENCE: So another
thing about moving away
from physical books-- I feel
like, to a certain extent,
there's a sentimental
value of having
a physical book by your favorite
author, possibly signed.
And do you see the
market of that?
How do you see that?
SETH GRAHAME-SMITH: I don't
think that physical books are
ever going to
completely disappear.
I think there will always be
a market for physical media.
You're looking at a guy who
still buys movies on Blu-ray.
And, by the way, if I
have a favorite movie,
I will download it
through either iTunes
or-- through Play, through Play!
I'm sorry.
What was I talking about?
Right.
I'll open Chrome.
I'll go to BitTorrent.
No, never.
And then I will also buy
the physical version,
just so I have it.
I am a collector.
And the same is true of books.
The books that I love, they're
on my Kindle or my iPad.
But they're also physical.
I buy the physical because
I want them on my shelf
because when you walk
into someone's home--
and this is probably still
a generational thing--
but their bookshelf
looks back at you
and is a representation
of at least how they
want you to see them.
So it could be, look
at how smart I am
or look at how much
I love vampires.
So no, I didn't mean to
say that the physical is
going to disappear.
I think that physical
books will become vinyl.
And if you look at
vinyl, the vinyl sales
from five years
ago, six years ago
are actually way up because
it went away for a while.
And then it became cool.
And now everyone in
Brooklyn buys vinyl.
But I think that books,
just for the very reason
you said, that the physical--
just like I don't think
retail will ever completely
disappear because there's
something about going into a
store not knowing what you want
and just feeling
things and having
a tactile retail experience
that people are always
going to crave.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
SETH GRAHAME-SMITH: Thank you.
Yes, sir.
Do you want to close it out?
AUDIENCE: A question
on your-- starting
with your "Pride and
Prejudice and Zombies,"
you kind of supposedly
created the mash-up market.
SETH GRAHAME-SMITH:
People say that.
I didn't say that.
AUDIENCE: What was your
inspiration and process,
that you suddenly came
up with this kind of idea
of these coming together?
And then the second
part is, do you
think because you're going
to the digital media, the way
that you write, the output
you kind of produce,
how is that maybe changing
versus your primary market
being physical?
SETH GRAHAME-SMITH: Interesting.
For the first part, I can't
take credit for the inspiration.
The inspiration belongs to a
man named Jason Rekulak, who
was my editor at
a small publishing
company in Philadelphia
called Quirk.
And I had been pestering
him about wanting
to write something fictional.
And they weren't a
fictional house back then.
I had written some
books for them
that-- well, I'll let you look
them up if you feel like it.
But they're different.
And I loved working
for them, but I
was dying to do
something fictional.
And it was Jason who
came up with the idea
of, well, why don't we put
something weird with something
old?
And so he had made this list.
On the left-hand
column was "Wuthering
Heights" and "Janey Eyre"
and "Pride and Prejudice"
and "Sense and Sensibility".
And on the right, it was
ninjas, pirates, werewolves.
And he was just sitting
there at his desk
and just drawing connections.
And he called me, and he said--
and I'll never forget this call
because it's the call that
completely turned my life
upside-down-- what about
"Pride and Prejudice"
with zombies in it?
And I just said, I'll have
it for you in six weeks.
I was so excited.
I literally remember I was
in my little apartment,
just jumping up and down.
I read every Jane Austen book.
Well, I didn't read every one.
I don't think I read
"Northanger Abbey."
But, anyway, I read the big
ones and just immersed myself
in the voice and in the
period and annotated
my little "Pride and Prejudice"
copy with all my little ideas,
and then just sat down
writing for six weeks
and dashed it out.
Now, the second
part, I don't know,
is the short answer,
how my process
is going to change as things
become sort of more digital.
I think that you've
already seen people,
like the aforementioned
Stephen King,
experiment with
serialization on the web.
He did it with-- it was
called "Ride the Bullet."
And then he did it
with "The Green Mile."
And I think that
serializing online
and maybe doing a
paper chapter basis--
or even I've
thought about, well,
what if you release
a book as an app?
And each chapter is
essentially an in-app purchase?
So the app is free,
and you get the first,
say, three chapters
of a book for free.
Then if you want
to keep reading,
the next three
chapters are $1.99.
And the next few chapters are--
So I think this is
where we're headed.
I don't know how it'll
change the writing process
other than maybe the
end of each chapter
will have to be really enticing.
Every chapter will
be a cliffhanger.
But we'll see.
All I know is that
it is going to change
and that we're going to
have to change with it
and that everybody here is
working for a company that's
going to be a major
part of that change.
And so I'm glad we all have
had this chance to chat.
I'm really appreciate that
you guys took the time
and really appreciative to Simon
and everyone here at Google
for having me back
for another talk.
And I love being here.
So give yourselves a hand.
Thank you so much.
Appreciate it.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]